the final steam controlers here and
while you're going to want your keyboard
and mouse back if you attempt to play an
FPS or MOBA a lot of games that used to
be unplayable on a game pad are now
accessible to the couch based gamer the
steam controller is a strange hybrid of
a classic gamepad like the Xbox 360
controller with touchpad similar to
those you'd find on a laptop these two
giant touch pads are the basis of this
whole design the one on the Left doubles
as a d-pad and except for when using the
digital keyboard mode to type that's all
I ever used it for the right touchpad
generally emulates either a mouse or
joystick but you can use it for other
functions too such as a steering wheel
or scroll wheel their paddles on the
back of the gamepad like on the new Xbox
one elite controller
they're perfect for shifting gears and
racing games but they aren't limited to
just that like all the inputs on the
steam controller
they're completely mapable you can use
the paddles to end your turn in
Civilization Sprint and Dark Souls or
cycle through weapons in Tomb Raider the
rest of the controller inputs are
standard with the traditional thumb
stick on the left before a B X&Y buttons
on the right pause and select and
triggers and bumpers the triggers have a
normal pull range with a distinct click
at full strength
you can customize these triggers
completely which allows you to optimize
the gas pedal and erasing sim or you
could set it up so on a first-person
shooter
you can aim down sights with the half
pole and fire the gun when you pull the
trigger all the way power comes from two
non-rechargeable double-a batteries
valve says you can get 80 hours off a
pair of batteries which puts the ps4
controller battery life to shame you can
connect to a PC simply using a USB cable
or use the wireless dongle that comes
with the standalone controller steam
machines don't require the dongle for
wireless use there's no headset jack on
the controller so you'll need a separate
solution for a mic and headphones when
you first pick up the controller it does
feel very awkward unlike every other
game controller I can think of the
handles curve upward which puts your
thumbs into position over the large
touch pads the steam controller requires
much more thumb dexterity than the
average controller a B X&Y buttons are
stretch and they're quite small and
close together
you'll probably press the wrong button a
few times as you get used to the reach
depending on the game with extended play
your thumb can get sore which kind of
sounds pathetic but it does happen
it's not how you want your controller to
make you feel so what can this
newfangled controller do that your
normal gamepad can't well mostly it can
act as a mouse and once you get the hang
of it you'll find it pretty easy to kick
back and play some games you've probably
never have expected to play with the
controller any game that requires simple
Mouse emulation and the handful of
button commands is a cinch to play
civilization 5 is extremely easy to pick
up and play with the default
configuration from the developer poly
bridge a game entirely dependent on
pointing and clicking is totally
playable when games get more complicated
though you're gonna have to do some work
Kerbal space program is one of those
games because it requires separate
controls for building and flying with
the steam controller you can switch
between different inputs quickly enough
in a game like this would definitely
require that once it is properly set up
you can play KSP with the steam
controller much better than you could
with a traditional controller when
constructing a rocket the mouse
emulation just worked and you can map
the rest of the controller inputs to
keyboard commands while flying using the
paddles to control roll is pretty cool
it's a nice touch that other controllers
can't match whether the touch pad excels
at emulating a mouse it fails emulating
a thumb stick perhaps overtime firmware
updates and fine-tuning the controller
settings will improve the thumbstick
mimicking but currently thumb stick
emulation doesn't feel like it works
while using the touchpad is a thumb
stick in a first-person shooter the
touchpad does not feel precise and fast
enough to aim and shoot on the fly it
can be hard to find the center of the
pad with it thumb because there's no
indent or physical indicator changing
directions quickly can throw off the
sensor so your view ends up slowly
listing off in a random direction
attempting to make fine adjustments to
aim at a distant enemy felt entirely
pointless if you want to use a
controller to play a shooter you aren't
going to want to use this controller if
you insist on playing an FPS you can
still use the touchpad as a mouse but
turning around requires you to flick
your thumb a few times and lining up
precision headshots is still miserable
it's very difficult to get smooth
predictable motion you can play an FPS
with the steam controller but it felt
more frustrating than fun
despite first-person aiming being a
hassle third-person games that don't
require very precise camera controls
work perfectly fine Dark Souls 2 was
very comfortable to play and using the
mouse emulation to control the camera
just felt natural
- Maury derp was kind of an odd one the
game would play ideally by having the
controller mostly emulate gamepad
controls with just the right touch pad
acting as a mouse but Tomb Raider
doesn't allow gamepad and keyboard mouse
inputs at the same time so you have to
map the entire steam controller to the
keyboard which means in-game button
prompts ask for keyboard buttons so you
have to remember that the F keys should
be B + spacebar should be a and that can
be confusing to remember during a quick
key GE event aiming just like in an FPS
didn't feel great and I wouldn't play
multi-player with this controller but
the game was playable I still would have
preferred sticking to a classic
controller I also tried Starcraft 2
while the steam controller did perform
much better than an n64 controller
there's no chance I can match my
performance with the keyboard and mouse
and MOBAs are in the exact same boat in
DotA 2 I wouldn't want my teammates
using a steam controller game devs or
community members can upload controller
configurations for every Steam game and
the most popular ones will rise to the
top a short amount of time after the
public release of this controller there
probably won't be any issue finding
control schemes that work for every game
and you'll be able to easily tweak any
to your liking the steam controller is a
compromise between a gamepad and a
keyboard and mouse setup but it doesn't
really replace either one you'll still
need a keyboard and mouse for StarCraft
to league of legends or csgo you'll
still need a controller if you want to
kick back on the couch and play Call of
Duty BioShock Infinite or Far Cry 4 the
steam controller is definitely a useful
tool in the kit for the laid-back gamer
but I wouldn't throw away the old tools
yet
you